Now, who are the true Jews? Who are the
true Jews?
Who are the true Jews? All right.
Let's go here.
Romans 2:28-29.
Okay, let's go here. We're going to end
it here. We're almost done.
For he is not a Jew who is one
outwardly, nor is circumcision that
which is outward in the flesh, but he is
a Jew
who is one inwardly, and circumcision is
that which is of the heart by the
spirit, not by the letter, and his
praise is not from men, but from God.
Those who are baptized in Christ,
spiritually circumcised, you are a real
Jew, and you are really circumcised.
Okay?
Now, watch here. Galatians 3.
15-18. Brothers, I speak Listen, we're
almost done.
Brothers, I speak in human terms. Even
though it is only a man's covenant, yet
when it has been ratified, no one sets
it aside or adds conditions to it. Now,
the promises were spoken to Abraham and
to his seed.
He does not say, "and to seeds," as
referring to many, but rather to one,
"and to your seed." That is Christ.
Notice, who is the real seed of Abraham?
Christ Jesus.
Who is the real seed of Isaac? Christ
Jesus. Who's the real seed of Jacob?
Christ Jesus. Who's the real seed of
Eve, the woman? Christ Jesus. Who is the
seed that will bless the world and bring
about the promise to Abraham? Christ.
Christ.
Christ, not Israel. Christ.
And what I'm saying is this.
The law Moses, which came
years later, does not invalidate a
covenant previously ratified by God. The
law of Moses cannot make null and void
the covenant with Abraham.
Cuz the covenant of Abraham is not based
on keeping the law of Moses. The
covenant of Abraham is based on trusting
God, obeying God to tell you what to do
when he tells you to do it. So now he
tells you believe in Christ and you will
receive the promise, not follow the law
of Moses.
For if the inheritance, remember this,
inheritance is by law, it is no longer
by promise, but God has granted to
Abraham through promise. So now who
receives the inheritance?
Who receives the promise of Abraham?
All right. Who?
Who? Let's see.
Galatians 3:26 one end. Almost not, I
promise you. Almost not. Did I read this
over here?
Did I Yeah.
Oh, yeah. I I had it here. Sorry.
Cuz I'm so dumb, it's right here. Okay,
let me do it here. See, that's what I
thought.
All right, so let's do it here.
Watch here.
Going out with a bang.
Who receives inheritance, the promise?
Those who are the seed of Abraham.
How do you become a seed of Abraham?
Galatians 3:16, the seed is Christ,
right? Galatians 3:26-29.
For you are all sons of God through
faith in Christ Jesus. For all of you
who are baptized into Christ have
clothed yourselves with Christ.
There's neither Jew nor Greek. There's
neither slave nor free man. There's no
male and female. For you are all one in
Christ Jesus. And if you belong to
Christ, then you are Abraham's seed.
Bye-bye, Israel.
The real seed of Abraham
are those baptized in Christ.
The real Jew is the one baptized in
Christ. The one who's really
circumcised, those baptized in Christ.
And if you're baptized in Christ, then
the promises of Abraham are yours.
Are yours, right?
What are those promises though?
You got You guys want to get shocked?
What are those promises?
Let me just get rid of this here.
Sorry.
Watch here. Let's see what those
promises are.
Galatians 4, let's go there.
So, if you are baptized in Christ, you
are the real seed of Abraham, not
Netanyahu, and you will inherit the
promise. Okay. Galatians 4:1-7. Now, I
say, "As long as the heir is a child, he
does not differ at all from a slave, cuz
you're too young to claim your
inheritance.
So, you too have to be like a slave who
obeys,
although he's the owner of everything.
But, he is under guardianship sorts
until the date set by the father. So,
also we, while we were children, were
enslaved under the elemental things of
the world.
But, when the fullness of the time came,
God sent forth his son, born of a woman,
born under the law,
subjected himself to the law to fulfill
it,
>> [snorts]
>> so that he might redeem those who are
under the law, that way we might receive
the adoption as sons. Because you are
sons of God, sons, God sent forth the
spirit of his son into our hearts
crying, "Abba, Father."
Therefore, you are no longer a slave,
but a son. And if a son, then an heir
through God. You're the heir. You're the
seed of Abraham, the son of Abraham.
When you're baptized in Christ, you are
a Jew inwardly and circumcised
spiritually. So then, what do you
receive as the heir?
We already read about Sarah, right?
Sarah
points to Jerusalem, who's our mother.
For it is written,
Galatians 4:27-31.
"Rejoice, barren woman, who does not
give birth. Break forth and shout, you
are not in labor, for more numerous are
the children of the desolate one than of
the one who has a husband. Now, watch
what Paul is doing. He's taking Old
Testament text about the nation Israel
and applying it against the Jews who
reject Jesus and applying it to the
church saying, you are now that Israel,
church.
And you, brothers,
in accordance with Isaac are children
promised. Damn.
Isaac is our ancestor.
Five more minutes, we're done.
Wait, if you're a Gentile and you're
baptized in Christ,
you are now the seed of Abraham
and you are
Isaac's descendants.
In fact, his brothers.
You?
But if you're a Jew and you reject
Jesus, you are an Ishmaelite? Ishmael's
your brother? Your ancestor and Hagar's
your mother?
Damn. What do you think they would do to
Paul today
if he was in Israel?
But now watch what Genesis 21 said.
Sarah told Abraham, the bondwoman or son
will have nothing to do with my son. And
God said, yes, listen to what she said.
Let them leave. Banish them.
I'll be with Isaac. I'm sorry, I'll be
with Ishmael. I'll make him a great
nation, but he has no promise with
Isaac. So, listen to Sarah, get rid of
them.
So, then he says, the Jews who reject
Jesus are your Ishmael. Get rid of them.
The Jews
who claim
you must follow the law
and be
an Old Testament Christian following the
law? Get rid of them. They're
Ishmaelites. And Ishmael and Isaac
cannot cohabit, coexist.
Treat them like
Sarah treated Hagar and Ishmael. Banish
them from Isaac, and you are Isaac.
You are one with Isaac. You're like
Isaac. Banish the Jews who reject Jesus
or say you must keep the law.
But as at the time he was born according
to the flesh as first getting him, was
born according to spirit, so it is now
also. But what does the scripture say?
Quoting what Sarah told Abraham in
Genesis 21, "Cast out the servant woman
and her son."
But who is the servant woman? Jerusalem
on earth.
Who is her son?
Any Jew that says you must keep the law
or rejects Jesus.
For the son of the servant woman shall
not be heir with the son of the free
woman. Who are the sons of the free
woman? Sarah, who's the picture of
heavenly Jerusalem, our mother. You. So
then, brothers, we are not children of a
servant woman, but of the free woman.
So if you are now the seed of Abraham
and like Isaac, the children of promise,
what is your inheritance?
What is your inheritance so we can now
end it?
Here's your inheritance. Romans 4:1-17.
Pay attention to 13.
What then shall we say that Abraham our
forefather according to the flesh has
found? Now he's talking to physical
Jews. Notice,
Abraham's either your father
physically
because you're a physical Jew, or is
your father spiritually cuz you're
baptized in Christ and you're a
spiritual Jew. So now he's talking to
the physical Jews according to the
flesh. So you Jews who are the physical
seed of Abraham, but may not be true
Jews inwardly.
For if Abraham was justified by works,
he has something to boast about.
But not before God. For what does the
scripture say? Abraham believed God and
was counted to him as righteousness.
Now, to the one who works
and he's talking about works of the law.
To the one who thinks you must keep
doing the works of the law
and that's the only way to be saved then
you're putting God in a situation that
the only way he can save you is by doing
the law and he's obligated to do so.
Baloney.
But to the one who does not work but
believes upon him who justifies ungodly,
his faith is counted as righteousness.
Just as David also speaks
of the blessing on the man to whom God
counts righteous apart from works of the
law.
Why am I adding law? Cuz that's the
context, circumcision.
This is the context. He's dealing with
his physical brethren, the Jews, the
physical descendants of Abraham saying,
"Keep the law of Moses
and believe in Christ. That's the only
way you can be saved."
Blessed are those whose lawless deeds
have been forgiven and whose sins have
been covered. Blessed is the man whose
sin the Lord will not take into account.
Now, watch what your inheritance is.
Therefore, is this blessing on the
circumcised? Is it only for you Jews?
Or on the uncircumcised also?
Is it not also for the Gentiles? That's
what circumcised means. The Jews,
circumcised. Gentiles, not circumcised.
For we say faith was counted to Abraham
as righteousness. How then was it
counted? When was Abraham made
righteous?
While he was circumcised or
uncircumcised? Not while circumcised.
You see how he's burying them?
Abraham, your father, was a Gentile.
He wasn't a Jew.
Abraham became a friend of God, pleasing
to God
when he trusted God to give him the land
long before he got circumcised. You see
how it comes full circle?
See what Paul is doing here?
It comes full circle.
God began with a Gentile uncircumcised,
made him his friend and loved him and
promised to bless him, and that Gentile
believed in him.
Hence,
your origin, Israel, started in an
uncircumcised Gentile. So, why are you
now demanding the Gentiles to be
circumcised to be pleasing to God and be
saved?
See how brilliant Paul is? He just
buried them.
Your origin begins
in a Gentile who was uncircumcised,
whom God loved, God was pleased with,
and became the friend of God just by
trusting God's promises.
And that same God of that Gentile
uncircumcised believer is the same God
who will now justify, glorify, justify,
transform, and save uncircumcised
Gentiles
who, if they trust in Christ, become
spiritually circumcised.
See the irony here?
You Jews began with an uncircumcised
Gentile, Abraham.
He wasn't circumcised
when God blessed him and loved him and
promised him and made him righteous
because he believed God, and he wasn't a
Jew.
And he received the sign of
circumcision.
He was given circumcision later
as the sign and the seal that he truly
possessed the faith that made him
righteous.
The righteousness that he already had
when he was uncircumcised. You see the
brilliance of Paul?
Why did God do it? So he could be the
father of everyone, you Jews who are
circumcised and uncircumcised Gentiles,
so they can be made righteous like he
was
when he was uncircumcised and a Gentile
by trusting the promises of God.
Man, he buried them.
Yeah.
But, what's your promise?
Right?
That he might be the father of all who
believe without being circumcised.
That righteousness might be counted to
them like it was to him. And the father
of you, too, circumcised Jews, if you
believe in Jesus.
To those who not only are of the
circumcision, but who also follow the
steps.
It's not mental ascent, faith alone, as
defined by Bible perverts like need
growth on women.net.
Faith means walking in faith,
following the steps of Abraham. That's
obedience.
The faith of our father Abraham, which
he had while uncircumcised. So, what's
the promise, guys? Your inheritance, the
world. For the promise
to Abraham and or to his seed. Who are
his seed? Galatians 3:29, we who are
baptized in Christ.
What's the promise? You will own the
world.
If you believe your Bible, Israel does
not belong to Netanyahu.
Israel does not belong
to the Orthodox Jews,
to the Zionists. It belongs to the
church.
If you're the seed of Abraham, the world
is yours.
And this promise that the world would be
his and his seed was given before the
law.
And it comes by the righteousness of
believing.
Believing in Christ and becoming
righteous. For those who are of the law
are heirs, faith has been made empty,
and the promise has been abolished. For
the law brings about wrath, but where
there is no law, there also is no
trespass.
For if this for this reason is by faith
in order that it may be according to
grace, meaning God's undeserved kindness
is what moved him to get forgive you and
give you these promises on the condition
you believe in Christ and walk in faith.
So, the promise will be guaranteed to
all the seed, not only those who are of
the law, but also to those who are of
the faith of Abraham, who's the father
of us all. As it is written, "A father
of many nations have I made you."
And in the presence of who whom he
believed, even God who gives life to the
dead and calls into being that which
does not exist. It's over. That's it.
So, Christians, are you Old Testament
Jews or New Testament Christians?
Are you Old Testament Jews or New
Testament Christians?
If you're New Testament Christians,
then the land of Israel does not belong
to the Jews who reject Jesus.
Any
ethnic Jew who rejects Jesus
is not of Abraham, is not of God,
and the land does not belong to them.
It belongs to the true seed of Abraham,
the church,
baptized into Christ, born of the
spirit, one with Christ, and walk in
that faith.
And that can include ethnic Jews who
believe.
It's over. We're done.